et priorité au direct de joe biden est
en train de s'exprimer depuis la maison
blanche sur la guerre en ukraine au
congrès pour l'aide humanitaire et
sécurité à four l'ukraine
pour contrer la nation ce moment
critique nous avons besoin de cette aide
doit soutenir l'ukraine dans sa lutte
pour la liberté contre la guerre brutale
nous devons faire notre part bien sûr
que cette alliance le coût de cette
lutte et bien sûr élevé mais le coup de
ne pas résister à une agression violente
et plus élevé
nous soutenons
le peuple ukrainien
tous les jours le peuple ukrainien paie
le prix et il paye avec leur vie nous
devrons donc contribuer dès d'armement
le financement les munitions et un
soutien économique pour faire en sorte
que leurs sacrifices et un but qu'ils
allaient va continuer à lutter il est
critique et d'approuver ce financement
le plus rapidement possible
bien avant que la russie ne lance cette
invasion j'ai été clair sur la réponse
des états unis en cas d'agression qui a
eu lieu nous avons dit que nous
n'allions pas envoyer des troupes mais
qu'elle nous allions fournir une
assistance militaire aux robustes
contre cette agression russe j'avais
parlé des sanctions et que nous allions
détruit en recettes ce mythe comme quoi
la russie pouvait agir sans que d'autres
réagissent dans le monde et notamment à
l'est
de avec des frontière avec l'ukraine
nous avons dit que nous avions protéger
ses frontières et c'est ce que nous
faisons mais malgré ce que dit le
kremlin
tout le monde voit très clairement mon
quels sont les faits ne nous sommes pas
en train d'attaquer la russie
nous aidons l'ukraine à se défendre
contre cette agression russe s est
l'invasion brutale
poutine pourrait décider de mettre fin à
cette agression la russie est
l'agresseur il n'y a pas de doute et
nous devons demander des comptes à la
russie la russie continue
vous faire payer d'un prix humain
extraordinaire
nous voyons de plus en plus c'est
évident ces atrocités des crimes de
guerre dans les zones qu'ils contrôlent
et tant que ces atrocités continue nous
allons continuer à fournir de l'aide
militaire
mais j'ajouterais entre parenthèses
ce week end il y avait une fête ici à
washington pour celle que la presse
pensez à la presse américaine le courage
et qu'il a fallu aux journalistes pour
rester dans cette zone de guerre tous
les jours qu'ils envoient des rapports
j'ai toujours eu beaucoup de respect
pour les journalistes mais je dois dire
que actuellement mon respect de cd
double quand je vois ces journalistes
dans les zones de feu
assuré que le monde puisse entendre la
vérité imaginez si on ne pouvait pas
avoir accès à cette vérité montre est
complètement différent depuis deux mois
elle lancement de cette attaque brutale
nous avons
déplacé invités comme
forme de soutien
et
nous avons pu envoyer des milliers
de systèmes de radar de systèmes anti
aériennes des munitions mais états unis
sonic dit système anti char ont chaque
achat angle rue qui se trouve en ukraine
10 points
nous devons essayer continuer à aider le
peuple crève
avec la fourniture d'armement nous et
notre parti ne pas retenir qu'ils
envoient des chars l'artillerie et
d'autres armes et tout cela se passe à
une vitesse record
il ya beaucoup de nouveaux équipements
qui sont déjà arrivés en ukraine et qui
peuvent être utilisés directement au
combat mais où nous avons
épuisé
nos autorités
qui existait déjà pour les dépenses en
ukraine 2 c'est à dire qu'il n'y a plus
de fonds prévus par le congrès et c'est
pour cela que séduit afin de soutenir
l'ukraine j'en vois
au congrès une proposition de paquet
législatif complet qui permettrait de
continuer ce soutien est de continuer
l'aide humanitaire
et ses fonds supplémentaires
aider les
forces armées dans les mois et les
semaines critique à venir
et cela va permettre le luxe de
l'agression russe il y aura des charmes
et
des armes anti aériennes
qui sont utilisés déjà par les
combattants ukrainien
en plus il y aura de l'assistance
humanitaire qui fait défaut actuellement
avec les une aide pour
l'alimentation et le sanitaire pour
aider aussi les réfugiés qui habite
l'ukraine g qui se trouvent dans
d'autres pays ça va me permettre de
paiement des pensions
le soutien social du peuple ukrainien
j'ai deux hôpitaux
il y à dépouiller un problème de crise
alimentaire qui se pointe au tour du
monde l'ukraine est un des plus grands
producteurs agricoles qui produisent
environ 10% du blême consommer dans le
monde
poutine gicquel et sanctions empêchent
je sais ce bled arriver sur le marché or
ce n'est pas vrai c'est la guerre de
poutine n'ont pas les sanctions qui
empêchent
la livraison
j'étais provisions par la mer car de
terre au toit du monde et cela va le
résultat sera à la hausse et des prix
en europe et ailleurs
nous allons donc se tenir les jeux
recteur américain à produire des
produits pour remplacer ceux qui ne
sentent qu'ils ne pourront pas partir de
l'ukraine et
de fonds supplémentaire va aussi dans
maintenant l'expansion de cette
production domestique et la mise en
réserve des matériaux comme le nickel et
de lithium qui ont été perturbés par la
guerre en ukraine et qui sont
nécessaires pour les systèmes de défense
comme pour la construction automobile
j'espère que le congrès va adopter
rapidement cette proposition voilà pour
cette conférence de presse de joe biden
qui a réitère son soutien donc à kiev
nous n'attaquons pas la russie a dit le
président américain mais nous aidons
l'ukraine à se défendre il va demander
au congrès une nouvelle enveloppe donc
en soutien à
l'ukraine